10 mai 1981 après 27 ans à droite la
france bascule à gauche françois
mitterrand est élu président de la
république c'est l'heure du changement
le socialiste veut aller vite avec son
premier ministre pierre mauroy retour
sur certaines de ses réformes qui ont
marqué le début de sa présidence
premier objectif augmenter le smic
c'était l'une des promesses de
mitterrand est c'est fait le 1er juin
1981 22 jours seulement après son
élection le gouvernement accorde un coup
de pouce de 10 % l'augmentation vous
allez bénéficier si vous deviez l'a
consacré à des achats une consommation
quelconque qu'est ce que vous feriez est
ce que mange et orio priorité autre
promesse celle de mettre fin au monopole
d'état sur les radios
là aussi c'est fait dès le début du
mandat de mitterrand les radios pirates
ne sont plus illégales elles deviennent
des radios libres
certains de leurs créateurs regretteront
peut-être le temps de la clandestinité
ou d'une cave ou d'un toit on pouvait
diffuser à l'aide d'un léger répéteurs
comme un vince ou radio manivelle
sévices est il ya encore deux ans autre
grande réforme voulue rapidement par
françois mitterrand l'abolition de la
peine de mort elle fait partie des 110
propositions de la gauche pour la france
à la manoeuvre robert badinter alors
garde des sceaux le 17 septembre 1981
très ému il défendrait son projet de loi
à l'assemblée nationale
quel honneur au nom du gouvernement de
la république de demander à l'assemblée
nationale l'abolition de la peine de
mort en france
c'est officiel le 30 septembre 1981
la loi est adoptée la peine de mort est
abolie
les mois suivants d'autres réformes
s'enchaînent janvier 82 nouvelles
avancées sociales une ordonnance abaisse
la durée légale du travail et instaure
la cinquième semaine de congés payés
c'est une avancée sociale très
importante car pour la première fois
depuis 936 on vient d'abaisser la durée
légale du travail
trente neuf heures au lieu de 40 heures
1982 toujours autre réforme
yvette roudy alors ministre des droits
de la femme veut rembourser l'ibg le 10
décembre
elle vient présenter son projet de loi
devant une assemblée nationale à moitié
id et la faille de sécurité sociale que
l'on signe c'est pour elle la levée
d'une certaine forme de réprobation
sociale qui pèse encore trop souvent sur
un acte que les êtres humains adultes
que les femmes sont devenues n'en
déplaise à certains un acte quel
n'accomplisse jamais de gaieté de coeur
la loi roudy est adoptée le 20 décembre
d'autres réformes ont marqué le début de
la présidence de mitterrand la création
de l' isf la retraite à 60 ans ou encore
les loi de nationalisation de 1982
[Musique]